can you imagine hawkeye as a high school
junkie or captain america as an s.a.t
score thief what about tony stark
playing second banana to a football star
played by anthony michael hall
these are the early roles that mcu
actors want you to forget
with films totaling over 27 billion
dollars in career box office earnings
samuel l jackson is a hollywood force to
be reckoned with he's also the highest
grossing actor of all time his movies
have earned enough to buy a shield
hovercraft with plenty left over of
course it helps that jackson has played
supporting roles in two of the biggest
franchises ever the mcu and star wars
make no mistake jackson is a movie star
who makes bank just not in amos and
andrew this 1993 comedy clearly had
aspirations of being funny but it fell
way way short of them as its dismal
reviews demonstrate it's a shame because
amos and andrew stars the promising duo
of nicholas cage and samuel l jackson as
a low-rent criminal and the playwright
whom the cops hire to kidnap
respectively satire is tough to pull off
and bad satire is hard to sit through
amos and andrew is the latter with
jackson struggling to work within the
limits of his two-dimensional straight
man and cage going only half gonzo in an
oddly muted performance
jackson made plenty of bad movies early
in his career but as one of his first
starring roles amos and andrew is one
he'd surely like you to forget about
going from child star to movie star
isn't easy that's a lesson young actors
have often learned the hard way scarlett
johansson managed to push through after
her breakout role in robert redford's
the horse whisperer which she made when
she was just 13. over the course of her
career johansson's movies have made over
15 billion
with many of them featuring her in above
the title roles however she may consider
herself lucky to have made it to the
horse whisperer in the first place as
her earlier roles showed promise but not
profit in 1994 she played john ritter's
daughter in rob reiner's north starring
elijah wood as a kid searching the globe
for the perfect mom and dad north earned
scathing reviews including a rare zero
stars from roger ebert who famously
wrote i hated this movie hated hated
hated hated hated this movie hated it
what
what's wrong with it it looks totally
normal after her next film just cause
didn't fare much better her agent
probably thought a home alone movie was
a slam dunk except that movie was home
alone 3 and it didn't star macaulay
culkin the film's bad reviews and a poor
box office performance might have sent
johansen on the first bus back home but
she thankfully stuck around hollywood
long enough to be in the horse whisperer
instead and the rest is history
credit is due to director joe johnston
for seeing nobility honor and leadership
when he cast chris evans as steve rogers
in 2011's captain america the first
avenger why because evans had spent most
of his career up to that point playing
insufferable jerks his feature debut was
in 2001's not another teen movie which
was part of the rash of spoof films to
come out following the success of scary
movie as bad as that early role was it
wasn't his worst that dubious honor goes
to his second film the perfect score in
the film evans plays kyle the studly
member of a group of high school friends
who set out to steal sat questions in
preparation for the test the group is
led by francesca played by scarlett
johansson making the perfect score one
of her worst early roles as well the
premise of a teen comedy heist flick
showed promise but just like a high
school slacker it failed to live up to
its potential earning bad reviews from
both critics and moviegoers
the box office return was likewise
terrible with only 10 million dollars
earned worldwide evans also starred as
johnny storm in fantastic four a few
years later but he didn't fully hit his
stride until he donned the stars and
stripes
national lampoon was once one of the
most prestigious names in big screen
comedy with such classics as animal
house vacation and christmas vacation
however 1995's national lampoon's senior
trip doesn't belong on that list or on
any list other than this one here the
mcu star in question is jeremy renner
the man behind hawkeye nearly two
decades before playing the world's
greatest marksman renner missed the mark
with his big screen film debut to set
the stage know that the poster for the
film featured the lincoln memorial with
the tagline four score and seven beers
ago yeah it's that kind of bad renner
stars as mark daggs dogostino a party
dude teenager from the ohio suburbs
whose high school class gets invited to
washington dc as a ploy by a u.s senator
renner gives a solid impression of sean
penn's jeff spicoli from fast times at
ridgemont high but senior trip trades
that movie's wit for bro humor that's
about as subtle as a keg stand i know
you like me
his first movie is also arguably his
worst with bad reviews and an abysmal
4.6 million dollar box office
performance
if earth's mightiest heroes were a
basketball team don cheadle's war
machine would be the sixth man which
given how many avengers there actually
are in the mcu now is still saying
something while cheadle has never been
the lead his turn as colonel james
rhodes has definitely been a valuable
addition to the avengers and the
franchise cheadle wore his character's
titanium alloy suit like a glove which
makes sense since iron man 2 wasn't
actually his first foray into the
superhero genre that came 17 years
earlier in 1993's the meteor man in that
film robert townsend plays a high school
teacher in a rough urban neighborhood
who develops superpowers after being
struck by a meteorite think dangerous
minds meets armageddon
don cheadle plays goldilocks a member of
the community's biggest gang though the
movie isn't good cheedle tweeted about
the experience in 2020 and seemed to
have a good sense of humor about his
role in the film that said he still
probably wouldn't mind if you just
forgot about the meteor man
with an academy award on her mantle for
2015's room brie larson was a big name
before she became captain marvel in 2019
and with more than one billion dollars
in global grosses for captain marvel the
second best solo superhero debut in the
mcu behind only black panther she's
become an even bigger star since while
she won her oscar in her mid-20s larson
had been acting in hollywood for more
than a decade by then including bit
parts and several b movies but one of
her biggest misses came via the trouble
with bliss which sank like an infinity
stone in 2011. in the film michael c
hall plays morris bliss a jobless and
broke bloke in his mid-30s who begins a
relationship with his former high school
classmate's 18 year old daughter played
by larson larson is in pure manic pixie
dream girl mode here in a performance so
full of quirky charms she'd make zoe de
chanel go goth oh no based on its
dreadful reviews it's clear the trouble
with bliss in fact has many troubles not
least of which is that it tries so hard
to be eccentric that it never bothers to
be interesting within the decade larson
would be winning the academy award and
featured in the highest grossing film of
all time so it'd be a marvel if she
remembers the trouble with bliss
hollywood's efforts to turn chris
hemsworth into a movie star following
his success as thor have been pretty
spotty with his occasional hits
consistently interspersed with box
office disappointments
hemsworth came onto the hollywood stage
relatively quickly as thor was only his
fourth major film rule his biggest early
career disaster was in 2010's cash cash
is a sean bean star vehicle released in
2010 just a year before game of thrones
premiered the film ironically didn't end
up earning much cash the earnings were
about 46 000 at the box office or
roughly how much it costs to do
hemsworth's hair for a thor movie to be
fair cash had a limited theatrical
release and went straight to dvd in the
uk
[Music]
gosh
in the film hemsworth plays a guy who
discovers a briefcase full of money
spends it all and then finds out that it
belonged to sean bean's character who
wants his money back based on the film's
reception a lot of moviegoers probably
wanted their money back as well
benedict cumberbatch rose to stardom
because of his high functioning
sociopath interpretation of sherlock
holmes in sherlock and he rose even
higher as the eponymous master of the
mystic arts in doctor strange however
somewhere out there in the multiverse of
madness cumberbatch's career never
recovered from his early role in the
2009 biopic creation
while arguably not the star's worst
movie it's his most noteworthy misfire
before the premiere of sherlock in 2010.
in creation paul bettany plays charles
darwin whose faith in god is shattered
after the death of his daughter he then
must decide whether or not to finish his
landmark on the origin of species over
the objections of his devout wife
spoiler alert he does cumberbatch plays
joseph dalton hooker another prominent
scientist of the time who encourages
darwin to complete his magnum opus
fortunately for cumberbatch it's a small
role so he didn't suffer any major
setbacks from starring in this 108
minute yawner the film moves about as
fast as evolution and it earned bad
reviews from critics and moviegoers
alike
fortunately survival of the fittest was
kind to cumberbatch's career but he
still probably wouldn't mind if you just
forgot about his role in creation
as wanda maximoff aka the scarlet witch
elizabeth olsen can craft magical hexes
that bring pretty much any reality she
wants into existence if olsen possessed
those same kinds of powers in real life
she'd probably try to cast a spell to
erase very good girls from her
filmography released in 2013 one year
before godzilla and two years before
avengers age of ultron very good girls
is a very bad movie that wastes its
excellent cast
olson and dakota fanning play two
teenagers whose friendship is tested
when they both pledge to lose their
virginity before college then fall for
the same guy it's basically like if
american pie were trying for indie drama
vibes instead of gross out raunchy
comedy whatever the writers were going
for the result is arguably the worst
movie of olson's career like he'll never
slap me on the bed again to be honest we
could list a lot of robert downey jr's
early movies here yes he was featured in
a number of excellent films including
kiss kiss bang bang natural born killers
wonder boys and chaplin for which he was
nominated for an oscar but he also
appeared in some real stinkers in fact
the star developed something of a
reputation for box office bombs there
are certainly a number of contenders for
downey's worst movie but only one really
warrants the top spot johnny be good
don't let the name fool you it's bad
really really bad
released in 1988 the film stars downey
as leo wiggins best friend to hot shot
quarterback johnny walker who is being
heavily recruited by elite colleges
across the country
unfortunately the would-be comedy satire
is neither funny nor thought-provoking
as roger ebert stated in his half-star
review the people who made this movie
should be ashamed of themselves downey
himself may feel the same way and while
he's made plenty of bad movies both
before and after iron man looking at you
doolittle johnny b good takes the cake
it's not only the worst movie of the
star's career but also one of the worst
to feature an mcu actor period
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you